δεν πιστεπε ότι θα εξεικονομίσουμε προσωπικώ αλλά θα προσπαθήσουμε να μη χρειαστούμε περισσότερων προσωπικών για
τις περισότερες υπηρεσίες που θα χρειαστεί η κοινωνία εκε νομίζω ότι πρέπει να βάλουμε της
προσπαθείς μας επίσεις ότι θα έχουμε τη δυνατόλητα να βελτιώσουμ τις ιατρακές μας υπηρεσίες αυτό
είναι γεγονώς διαδι ο γιατρός έχει στη τη δυνατότητα ενώς συμβολου ου μέσα ση μικρό
χρονικώ διάστημα πουρείνα του δώσει κάποιες πληροφορίες τις οποίες διαφορικά πρέπει να ψάξει σε μεγάλον
αριθμό ςμεγά χρειαστεί μεάλο χρόνο για να τις βρεή και για α τις αξιολογήσει το
δεύτερο είναι ότι στις απεικονήσεις ι ατρική σήμερα εργάζεται και με τις απεικονήσεις δηλαδή πρέπει
να δει το της ικνες της ακτυνογραφίας πρέπει να δει τις κώνες το ιστοπαθολογικού τακύτα
πρέπει να δει ο δερατο λόγος το δέρμα πρέπει ο εν το ενδοσκόπος να αξιολογήσει
αυτά απου βλέπει μέσα στο και αυτό όλες αυτής τις απεικονήσεις μπορούν με ο ειάη
με την αρτυφήσιο λυμτέρες αυτής να αξιου λογηθούν καλύτερα τώρα τοπώσ θα ξελιχθεί ενθα μας
δώσει τη δυνατό ήταν αργότερα από την τεχνητή ο ημοσίη να πάμε στην τεχνητή εφιγία
και πως αυτά είναι ερωτιμετα τα οποία ακόμη δεν μπορούμε να τα απαντήσουμε όμως οπωσδήποτε
χρειαζόμαστε αυτό το οπλο και δεν μπορούμε να μην το αξιολογισώς